604 on a tuesday morning it is a very
busy day of course for politics a jammed
republican gubernatorial primary a very
close gop race for senate as well as a
lot of races going on because it is
primary election day and a lot of the
country looking at nevada as well of
course this determines who appears on
the general election ballot come
november mary jane belly is joining us
live at one of those polling locations
which opens in a little less than an
hour mary jane
yeah heather and john you know it's been
a windy day so far but it is election
day and you know it's a day many people
are looking forward to as they come out
to vote polling locations open up in
just under an hour i'm here at
centennial center and according to the
clark county website it's one of the
busiest voting locations here in clark
county now again those polls open up at
7 a.m this morning and heading into
today's primary election more than 68
thousand ballots have already been cast
statewide early voting totals have not
yet been released but the official total
in clark county for early votes was at
68
314. now if you miss the chance to vote
early you can still drop your ballot off
in person or vote in person at any
polling station today all ballots that
are mailed must be postmarked on june 14
or earlier to be counted and ballots
received through june 18th will be
counted now polls open up at 7 a.m but
they also close at 7 pm and officials
tell us you know they're expecting it to
be quite busy so get here early if you
can just expect long lines again pulling
locations close at 7 p.m reporting live
here at centennial mary jane vallieza
live local now